[Music]
and we're still talking about trying to
solve the problem of speeders on our
streets including your thoughts on
making it so cars can't even go 100
miles an hour
well we start with more immediate
suggestions our mary jane bellezza
talked with nyla marquez who lives near
the intersection where those nine people
were killed by a hundred mile an hour
driver she likes the idea of more radar
enforcement maybe it'll help you be like
oh wow i'm going way too fast i need to
slow down a little bit retired police
officer david colier says tickets from
red light cameras would be worthless if
people who get them get away with
ignoring them if you're not going to go
to jail and you're not going to get a
ticket that means anything and it goes
to collections what do you think other
people going to do in the community
all right viewer kathleen is one of
several who wrote in saying there's no
need to be able to drive at anything
over 70 even on highways long distance
she writes i've always wondered why 120
or more even appears on the speedometer
feel free to chime in we'll keep sharing
your comments in the meantime buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone here's the email address it's
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com